from above the wennington fire it's just
a few miles over tinder drive fields and
suburbs before you come to the next
an entire block of houses fully ablaze
in dagenham
spread over parkland park cars and
gardens to neighbouring buildings by a
steady hot breeze
and from a rooftop in dagenham the sheer
scale of london's fires becomes clear
like the wennington fire many seem to
have started on scrubland before being
blown into people's homes
the wild urban interface is when when
the forest ends and
the city or the town starts under a heat
wave you you have more fires you have
more fires that you would have otherwise
and these fires
are propagating faster they are
releasing more energy and they are
difficult more difficult to stop so it's
a worst case scenario
further into the city buildings were
burning too
oh my god
it's too much now a local resident
filmed the start of this intense fire
behind a row of shops in north west
london it's going to be points exploding
please all right
please get out of here i take like two
three kids out in some woman out from
the fire
so
i knocked the old doors so nobody here
and i helped my best to people
it's taken eight appliances from across
london to bring this blaze in north
wembley under control now fires are an
everyday occurrence in our big cities
but when temperatures went over 40
degrees in the capital today that
changed everything we tend to think of
wildfires as things that happen in other
parts of the world in france spain
california and so on and seeing these
wildfires here in the uk in the last
couple of days i think has really
brought home the risks posed by climate
change and as temperatures increase as
the world gets warmer then we can expect
to see more wildfires in the uk
due to the sheer scale of the major
incident declared by the london fire
brigade it's not clear how many fires or
how many casualties there have been and
beyond the capital the pattern was the
same blazes from buckinghamshire to
south yorkshire
quite simply the heat we've seen today
has changed the physics of our towns and
countryside and the consequences are
catastrophic tom clark sky news